لأنه أول شيء مو واضح أيش منغولي مثلًا
أنا عندي متلازمة، وأنا إنسان طبيعي
أعتبروني شخص طبيعي، أعطوني فرصة
حمود سعدون الشمري، طالب موارد بشرية
عندي نوع من المتلازمات
تتفرع من متلازمة داون
لكن أنا اللي فيني بالضبط
اللي هو عدم تعرق، مشاكل مثلًا بالجلد
الحساسية وما الحساسية تقريبًا
«كيف كانت طفولتك؟»
أنا تأخرت سنة بالدراسة
وعشان أدخل مع أخوي مرة واحدة
أنا بيني وبينه سنة
دخلنا مع بعض، وواجهنا المجتمع مع بعض بشكل عام
هذا بداية جديدة لي
أو بحكم أنهم يبغون يعرفون
أيش يصير لي بالمدرسة بشكل عام
بحكم التواصل
مثلًا مع المدرسين
يبغون يعرفون أيش يصير لي بالضبط
كيف بواجه المجتمع؟
وما أشوف أنه له حاجة، خصوصًا أنه أنا منذ الصغر
لمّا أواجه مجتمع كثير
بتعلم وبتقبل كل شيء
«هل أفادتك الدراسة في المدارس العامة؟»
أنا أشوف أنه هذا الشيء خطأ
ليش؟ لأنه أنا مثلًا لما أدخل مع الأشخاص العاديين
بكتسب سلوكهم
وبكون شخص عادي
وبواجه مثلًا التنمر، عادي بالعكس
لأني أنا أول ما أطلع من المدرسة
بواجههم في الخارج
خلينا نقول مثال دخلوا خمسة أشخاص مثلًا
مدرسة معينة طبيعية
اللي كل الأشخاص فيها طبيعيين
هل الخمسة أشخاص قادرين يأثرون على 300 طالب مثلًا؟
أكيد لا
أكيد أنه 300 طالب هم اللي بأثرون عليهم
اللي هو يعتبر المجتمع بشكل عام
لمّا يتحدث، أنا بتطوّر منه
تتطور مهاراتي منه
أكتشف خبرات منه بشكل عام
«كيف تتعامل الأسرة مع ابنها المصاب بمتلازمة داون؟»
مثلًا يكون أحد الوالدين
يقول أنت ما فيك شيء مثلًا، أنت شخص طبيعي
من الأفضل أنه تعلمه وش اللي عنده هو
وش اللي هو يمر فيه أو وش اللي عنده
فيه أساليب معينة
لو قالوا أنه أنت عندك مثلًا كذا وكذا
بس هذا الشيء ما يعيقك أنك تمارس عملك
هذا أفضل بكثير
أو أنه شخص مثلًا تقول له ما فيك شيء
بس ينصدم من ردة فعل العالم عليه
يحس أنه لا
مثلًا هذا الشخص يكذب عليه
هو في شيء بس ما يقول
بس محاولة فهم الوضع اللي أنا فيه
وش اللي عندي أنا
أنا تصنفت مؤخرًا ترى
ما عرفت حالتي إلا بالأخير
فهذا كان السبب
«موقف لا تنساه في المدرسة؟»
لما أطرح استراحة، فسحة
يجتمعون علي طلاب المدرسة بشكل كامل
يكوّنون حولي دائرة
كان كل واحد من الطلاب
يدف جميله عليّ بدافع التخويف
أنه هذا شخص مثل ما تقولون
مثلًا بدون حواجب، بدون أسنان
كنت أقابلهم بين فترة وفترة معينة
كنت أشوف بعضهم في الشارع
كانوا هم اللي يتذكروني أنا ما أتذكرهم للأمانة
كانوا يقولون سامحنا، كنا نقول كلام سيء عنك
«ممارسات مجتمعية تزعجك؟»
لما يشوفون هذا الشخص كيف شكله كذا
يحسب أنه لما يمسكني أو يسلم علي هذا الشيء بيعديه
مثلًا يسلم ويمسح يده بثيابه
كنت أحس أنه أنا شخص غريب
ليش الناس يجتمعون علي ويشوفون شيء فيني أنا ما أشوفه؟
«ما الصعوبات التي تواجهك مع المتلازمة؟»
بحكم أني أنا ما أتعرق
ما عندي مسام بالجلد
ما فيه أي شي يبرد على الجسم
كان يقول الدكتور قبل
أنه الماء هذا ما يلقى مكان يصرف معاه وممكن يدخل مع الدم
يسبب إلى وفاة طبيعية لا سمح الله
«ماذا لو أورثت المتلازمة لأطفالك؟»
عادي يصير فيه تفاهم بيننا أنه ممكن ما نكمل فيه
ما ودي مثلًا يمر بالتجارب اللي أنا مريت فيها
لا مو ظلم، هذا قضاء وقدر بشكل عام
«ما الخيارات المتاحة لك في سوق العمل؟»
في الغالب متلازمة داون
أطلق المسمى هذا أن كل شخص يأخذ حقوقه بنفسه
كمتلازمة
لكن فيه ناس مثلًا يقول هذا عنده إعاقة
أو إعاقة جسدية وفكرية
سواءً كذا أو كذا
يحسب أنه هذا غير قادر على العمل
غير قادر على أداء الوظيفة
غير قادر على أن يؤدي مهارة له
كنت أستحي من الناس
أنه أنا عندي شيء
أنه عندي مشكلة شخصية أو صحية
أحرص أنه ما تنزل أي صورة لي
ما تنزل لي أي صورة في منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
ما يصورونك؟
أيه، أحرص أنه زملائي ما يسخرون بشكل عام
بس أكتشفت أنه لا، العكس
كلهم يمدحون، الحمدلله
كانت هذه
شرفتنا
لي الشرف
حياك الله، ونشوفك إن شاء الله قريب